moi ça m'est déjà arrivé par exemple nom
de m'envoyer en l'air en l'air non il ya
longtemps c'est pas vrai bah oui c'est
qui je ne sais plus
[Applaudissements]
paillage est alors née une jeunesse ou
des pv des plats faits week-end dans un
avion
décoller on a une jeune
était romantique c'était des francs ce
récif cet internat à bercy où l'avion
mais c'était sur un dans la cabine de
pilotage
comment
vernon en version n'a pas envie de
savoir ça va on a vu assez d'horreur oui
alors vous moi j'ai failli mais ça s'est
pas fait
comme l'ensemble de votre carrière mais
c'est resté dans un an mais n'y croient
toujours qu'ils vaquaient nikkei jamais
mais c'était dans un vol paris
strasbourg en fait
c'est vrai que j'en raffole paris
strasbourg normal qu'on leur dit
jean-pierre sa saucisse est
mort hier paris cambrai je me suis dit
on a envie de faire des métiers
non mais il y avait une fille tu étais à
quatre sièges de moi et je sentais
qu'elle met alors vous dire des
officiers
[Rires]
nazis c'est la psychose il ya tant
couach 127 dating à quelqu'un est
abondante
on avait une grosse connexion on avait
des contacts tout ça et on sait pas
parler moi j'allais attendre aux
toilettes je pensais qu'il allait me
rejoindre elle est jamais venu
non mais les choses qui se passent ainsi
très fort vous êtes suivis
d'ateliers
vraiment faut vraiment c'est important
c'est important pour beaucoup de gens et
c'est important pour nous et vous
n'aurez pas envie de le faire et on a vu
mon nom je pourrais pas je peux pas
prendre l'avion c'est aussi là il faut
faire comme dans barracuda dans les
souris
barracuda le pilote
comme ça pour que je montre dans la loue
ou the soul enfin un truc mais soyons
agen n'ont pas impossible mais par
contre j'ai fait ça dans un ascenseur
quoi ces moyens
d'aider préliminaire très poussé 10 ans
[Rires]
prenez ce que dira
on n'arrive pas
quoi les prévisions à la pause et un
débit les ascenseurs savez savez on
faisait taille
avec ces blocos indienne
mais c'est bon j'entendais drôle de
bruit là non mais sérieux et c'était
avec un gars avec quoi c'est pas
ça longtemps pas mais comment ça s'est
passé à côté en lâchant sur la censure
et à bloquer non parce qu'on était très
pressé ah oui mais quand on a des
propriétés bas parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais
baissé c'était une époque où je
dis presque normal parce que normal et
oui même avis et anti - sexuelle a bien
commencé quoi pitcher pas il y avait un
coup d'arrêt
alors il était donc voilà c'est fait le
plus fou que vous avez abbaoui parking
souterrain ciment femmes parking
au fait combien
créé mois au p 7
bah ouais mais c'est avec le même
nom
ouais mais en fait mais je veux alors
vous avez pris le parc le peut-être la
chanson pour halo parfois
même leur avait coûté non mais c'est
vrai écoutez moi je vous laisse faire un
en tout cas et depuis plus rien la
dernière fois c'était ou
dans un an et demi je pense dans un lit
son âge je pense que
l'embrasser nous regarde là où
onze easy a été incinéré
mais daniel l'a toujours dans sa tête et
dans son coeur
non c'est vrai c'était il ya combien
d'années 25
rendez compte ou pas ouais bah écoutez
en tout cas vous vous en souvenez c'est
l'essentiel